foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them mic
[Music]
k-e-y-m-o-u-n-t
haha Rhonda Santas You're Gonna Lose the
war with Mickey Mouse like a damn mature
guarantee you that but there's a war
going in on inside the Republican party
and we should be poking a stick at it
and drawing wedges in between every
single one of these fascists Good
Morning America it is Tuesday April 18th
it's Taco Tuesday it's Texas Paul
Tuesday here on the Tony Michaels
podcast thanks for joining us as always
as we prepare these wedges to drive them
through the Republican Party Donald
Trump is attacking Ron DeSantis this
morning for his attack on Disney
Florida man attacks Florida man for
hating gay people because that's truly
what this is right Rhonda santis doesn't
give two shits about Mickey Mouse or
Disney World let's face it he does he
got [__] married there he does not
give two shits about [__] Walt Disney
or wokeism or whatever it this is an
attempt to appear to be the biggest
bigot of the biggest they got they got a
[__] they gotta run for president and
they gotta run for king of bigots and
Ron DeSantis has set his sight
on the lgbtq community that's just
purely simple fact
he loves to oppress people especially
people who may or may not hold the same
sexual orientation that he does
he loves it he's a fascist I mean
fascists love to oppress people who
aren't them especially if they're a good
scapegoat for the problems that you want
to convince the Sheep masses
of now this is not playing well in the
rest of the country right this whole
Attack On Disney I know it feels like oh
yeah you know Disney's woke and this is
gonna sell but this wokeism [__] this go
woke go broke
um Florida's where Wilt goes to die is
not selling around the country the same
way as the Bud Light thing with Kid Rock
and all the [__] mongoloidites didn't
go well it just didn't go well it
doesn't it doesn't
it doesn't help their cause Donald Trump
realizes this
Donald Trump realizes this this morning
he's attacking Ron DeSantis
um for this war on Disney
because Donald Trump understands
something that people have that he can
take advantage of people's plight and
people's plight in Florida if if Disney
were to pack up and go which they're not
going to okay Disney's not gonna pack
their [__] and leave they're not gonna
sell off their properties they don't
need to
they don't need to they don't even need
Ron DeSantis
to make sure that they're they represent
a high percentage of Florida's economy
they don't need him
Rhonda santis knows that he's only
governor for like I don't know three and
a half more years
he knows that right and if he does run
and he wins in 2024 he's not going to be
the governor after that he won't
I don't think you'll run I don't think
you'll get the nomination even if he
does run but you know that's just me
what do I know
but Rhonda Rhonda santis
does he fully understand because
yesterday he said he's gonna build a
[__] prison next to Disney right and
this is all [__] nonsense he said he
was gonna take their special tax status
away from him and he didn't because he's
a weak coward this Ron DeSantis
he eats pudding with three fingers out
of a pudding cup okay who does that who
the [__] does that I mean I'm not saying
that chocolate pudding in a snack pack
isn't good I think there's a time and a
place you eat a snack pack maybe even
lick the remainder out of the out of the
[__] little disposable cup but eating
it with your fingers and sucking it off
your fingers come on Ron come on man
that and those white [__] rain boots
really
this is gonna be an easy slam dunk for
Donald Trump to beat Ron DeSantis
because Rhonda Santos does not sell
outside of Florida the reason why Rhonda
santis doesn't sell outside of Florida
is because he has no power outside of
Florida
Ronda Santos has no leverage no power
outside of Florida at all none
what could he possibly do besides try to
act like he's gonna build a prison next
to Disney because Disney's gonna have a
a pride day I'm not kidding you
Disney's like yeah you [__] with our tax
situation [__] you
the board that Ron DeSantis created
didn't do it because they're not gonna
piss off they're not gonna piss off the
company that's responsible for a huge
portion of their economy and it's not
just ticket sales and [__]
merchandise sales at Disney how many
[__] hundreds of thousands of people
you think every single month go to
Florida to visit a Disney property
huh
they're not gonna piss them off they're
not they're not gonna do it they're just
not gonna do it
especially over something like Disney
supports the inclusion of all people
into their organization and into their
fan base this is really [__] dumb
[__] this is the same stupid [__] when
when the little mermaid people freaked
out over The Little Mermaid her skin
color's different oh my God an imaginary
character they changed her skin color
for the live-action version what the
[__] are you people what are you so
pissed off about you're pissed off about
beer cans that don't have rainbows on
them I had to explain this to someone
last night they were like well where's
the where why where can you buy the Bud
Light cans and have rainbows on them I'm
like you can't buy Bud Light cans and
have anything on them but says Bud Light
these people that were destroying the
Bud Light cans couldn't find anything
but Bud Light Kansas said Bud Light on
them because it doesn't exist it's fake
it's phony it's all [__] they make
this [__] up Ron DeSantis is making his
war with Mickey Mouse up he's making the
[__] up and it's not it's he's gonna
face plant here and he's already doing
it
Trump is attacking Ron DeSantis on his
main platform here
Ron DeSantis main platform to catapult
him to be the nominee of president in
the United States in the Republican
party is he is responsible for the war
on wokism
that's his [__] platform that's what
he's gonna run on
and Donald Trump is attacking him
Donald Trump's supporters aren't walking
away from Donald Trump because he's
attacking Ron DeSantis for having awoke
war on Mickey Mouse no because it's a
cult you stupid bastard Rhonda santis
it's a cult man you're not gonna get the
cult to come with you just because
you're more of a bigot than Grandpa
poopy pants it's not gonna happen dude
you're you're [__] weak you're a
coward you don't look like Trump as much
as you try to look like Trump and
emulate Trump you're not him dude Ron
you just don't have the Charisma and
you're really frankly as educated as you
are you're a dumb [__] you are a
stupid son of a [__] and it only shows
the entire country who you are when you
say look I'm going after Disney because
they opposed the don't say gay bill
which the majority Americans would
oppose anyways dude it just doesn't make
sense but it's not supposed to folks
please
that's the thing about this whole thing
it's not supposed to make sense
I mean if you're looking for logic
in this entirety of this
of this stupid [__] timeline that
we're in you're gonna be here for a long
time searching
for some rational [__] thought
it's just not gonna happen it makes no
sense but it's not supposed to make
sense you see
it's not supposed to misinformation lies
[__] gaslighting and fascism aren't
supposed to make sense
especially in 2023
I mean
we we talked about it yesterday with
Jess Piper these [__] fascists in
Missouri Mike Moon the state senator
says he he wants to support 12 year old
girls getting married and then when he
gets caught on film
supporting it in a goddamn public
hearing he goes and makes a video and
makes it worse because he's like well of
course that's what I want to do because
Bible and Jesus and you know all that
stuff
yeah okay okay
Miranda Santos's war is not with Disney
it's not with Mickey Mouse
it's because Disney
is standing in his way
of being a full out bigot Disney says we
don't give a [__] if the governor of
Florida hates the lgbtq community wants
to get rid of the lgbtq community we
don't care if he wants to exclude him
from all public life in Florida we're
going to support them
and it's our First Amendment right to
[__] support them that's why Ron
DeSantis is pissed off Rhonda Santos is
pissed off because he knows Disney has
way more influence
way more say what happens in Florida
than some [__] two-term governor
Rhonda santis is not going to be
Governor forever Disney is going to be
in Florida forever Ron you stupid [__]
Disney ain't going anywhere you are your
time is ticking [__] so build the
prison I dare you
I think this is a great fight for Ron
DeSantis to have to prove to all the
Republican Party
and to America frankly ruin his absolute
political Ambitions here
by threatening to build a prison next to
a [__] next to a [__] Children's
theme park
these are the [__] who are
Banning drag show story hours people who
are trying to encourage and teach
children how to read they're banning
drag showers because oh man that's
[__] not safe to have someone reading
to children in a costume but oh my God
what's you know what we should do that
Children's theme park up there in
Orlando let's build a prison right next
to it that sounds safe as [__] for
children it sounds like Ron DeSantis
really gives a [__] about children
doesn't he
because it's not none of this [__] none
of it's about children the drag show
Story Hour the don't say gay Bill all
the [__] book Banning
all the [__] fascism that Rhonda
santis is trying to implement into the
Florida government
with his with his Governor's wand is all
about hatred every [__] single bit of
it all of it he's ignored Fort
Lauderdale
Jesus Christ the guy isn't even in
Florida today you think you would think
if Ron DeSantis was so hell-bent on
making sure that Disney who is
supposedly bad for Florida [__] out of
here Ron would be up in Orlando right
now nope guess where that [__]
is guess where the the governor of
Florida is today he's trying to whip up
[__] Florida congressmen to endorse
him and not Trump when they're all
endorsing Trump why do you think Donald
Trump is [__] attacking him this
morning Ron your window is closing man
here's what you do listen to me Ron
listen turn your [__] speakers up
[__] here's what you do you resign as
Governor today because the law won't
allow you to announce at this point and
be Governor resign as Governor today Ron
resign today and announce your running
that is the only [__] way that you
got a chance buddy that's it
that's it if you want to get in this
race Ron DeSantis get in it now I mean
right now like 10 minutes ago you should
be out in front of a microphone in
Washington DC with whatever [__]
no-name Congressman that you can whip up
to get out there with you in front of a
microphone and resign your seat as
governor of the state of Florida and run
now
because otherwise you're not going to
get the nomination you [__] ass [__]
I mean Donald Trump not only called you
a pedophile
now not only did he say that you're
going to destroy the the the the
country's safety net and Social Security
Medicare now he's saying that you're not
a [__] capitalist
you know who else is saying that Rhonda
Santos isn't a capitalist Chris Christie
Chris Christie
listen I I don't know if Ron DeSantis
knows this but there's no one who is
pro-anti Trump than Chris Christie Chris
Christie is is the trumpism fence
straddler in Chief I don't know if you
know this he's for Trump then he's
against him for him against him for him
against him for him against him
[__] Chris Christie said into a
microphone he doesn't even think Rhonda
Santos is conservative called him a
[__] liberal
let me tell you Chris
he ain't no [__] liberal and what
you're describing Chris I don't know if
you need a [__] Webster's Dictionary
but that ain't liberalism
so when you had the likes of Donald
Trump
who is the maga maga cult King and the
and and the Cheeto dust kiwin honor the
king attack dog
and you have Chris Christie I don't know
if you know who Chris Christie is or
what kind of weight Chris Christie
brings to a fight no pun intended
but Chris Christie will destroy Ron
DeSantis Donald Trump will destroy Ron
DeSantis and I'm here for it baby
he should put he's supposed to be there
new they're up and coming he's supposed
to be the fresh face he's the one that's
gonna bring fascism to America just like
he did the Florida
and they're gonna destroy him
absolutely burn him down with a
blowtorch and [__] piss on the hot
ashes good [__] em we not only should we
be clapping and cheering we should be
encouraging it
I don't know if you know this when the
story broke of Rhonda Santos eating
pudding with his three fingers
which is hilarious by the way these are
hilarious facts that should be known to
everyone in the public I mean
I mean manga can tolerate a Hitler
wannabe but someone who eats putting off
their fingers I don't know that they're
gonna go there
everyone should know this the day that
it dropped me and Gabe Sanchez told
Donald Trump's team because we know
they're listening to this show Liz we
know you're listening we know you're
listening in
we told them to do an ad and show Ronda
Santa's sucking pudding off his fingers
they did it
it is going to be the best commercial to
run against Donald Trump or Ron DeSantis
I can't wait
I can't wait hey Trump team hey hey guys
listen up do you want to know your next
strategy move do you want to know the
next ad that she you should be running
you should be calling Ronda santis a
liberal and not a conservative because
he wants to shut down one of the biggest
businesses one of the biggest Employers
in the State of Florida because he wants
big government control over business
that's your next one that's it that's
the one that's the one you run that's it
that's the one that's the one I want for
next year so do that one do that one
Trump team
I it's coming
I mean [__] he's posting about it
this morning
now Trump claims that Disney is gonna
leave Florida get the [__] out of here
are they're gonna threaten to leave
Florida the [__] are you talking about
you nincompoop
but Disney does not give two [__]
listen to me listen to me when I tell
you this this is very important in this
whole [__] political fight of Ron
DeSantis trying to act like he's at war
with Disney when he's really just trying
to be a hateful [__] bigot towards
lgbtq people okay
Disney does not give two [__] what
Rhonda Santos thinks or what Rhonda
santis is gonna do or says he's gonna do
they don't give a [__] the reason why is
because Ron desantis's clock is ticking
he's got three years
to do this prison okay good go for it
try it [__] so what you're gonna do is
waste your entire governorship
on some war with Mickey Mouse to build a
prison next to a children's theme park
okay good imagery there Ron
try it I'm sure Disney doesn't give two
shits of your thin veiled threats
they're not going anywhere they're not
gonna move because Ron DeSantis is going
to be governor for the next three years
they don't give two shits about Ron
DeSantis they'll be another fascist come
around in Florida I mean they're not
fascist and moved to Florida that they
can get these [__] elected
but there will be another one that
they'll have to deal with and they done
deal they've done dealt with Ron
DeSantis in the best way possible they
took his stupid [__] rhetoric about
their their their special Municipal tax
codes and they wanted him up and tossed
him in the [__] garbage and he lost
that fight he act like he won but he
didn't he didn't win [__] and that's why
he's [__] mad he's mad because Disney
supports the lgbtq community which is
bad for his PR it's bad for his fascist
state of Florida
and they're gonna have a pride day
and that really pisses him off I would
imagine I would imagine I would say that
we're gonna show video here on the Tony
Michaels show
I'm I would say we're going to show
video of actual Nazis showing up at
Disney to protest this Pride day
that Rhonda Santos has sent there doubt
me doubt mean that that Ron DeSantis is
sending these people all around the
state with Nazi Flags show me the proof
that he isn't
here boy we got a lot of news today Fox
News is also um they're selecting a jury
pool this morning I guess they got 12
jurors they're working on backup jurors
as they still pretend
um I think Dominion's gonna [__]
settle this thing and really Dominion's
gonna sell it and settle it for the
amount that they want because Fox News
can afford
um a lot a month to pay a lot of money
and still survive
uh this lawsuit with dominion and they
definitely do not want to go to trial
Fox News this is bad for Fox News on all
fronts and they're going to pay any
amount of money it takes to survive and
try to keep what reputation they have
left which isn't much
um the only people who still believe Fox
News are the people who believed it and
when they were blatantly lying to them
and then once they found out they were
lying they still believe in Fox News so
um so that news is going on there's also
news in the uh shooting in Kansas City
uh of the young man who walked up on the
wrong front porch while black
um the the the purse the shooter has
been charged with two felony counts they
have not arrested this person yet I
don't know what the [__] they're waiting
on but they have an arrest this person
yet now obviously people in the
community are calling for civil rights
charges as well because this this
shooting was racially motivated
obviously now the young man yarl is
doing I think he's doing better I could
believe this the story this morning he
was shot twice and he still was able to
go to I think three or four neighbors
houses before he could find someone that
could call for help
um so what a what a brave young man and
um I I hope that he recovers well and
he's able to
get his story out there and we can
make sure to get him Justice for what
happened while he was trying to pick up
his twin brothers
Hellboy
what a world we live in and there's a
lot of other news but today is Tuesday
it's Taco Tuesday and we have you know
what Taco Tuesday means we have Texas
Paul here today with us so Texas Paul is
going to join us I know he'll give us
his opinion on the uh Mickey versus
meatball meatball battle
and what he thinks about Ron DeSantis
threatening to build a prison next to
Disney World this is this is some this
is the stupidest [__] timeline what
in the actual [__] are we doing holy
[__]
um also I can't wait to see what he has
to say about yesterday's uh sham fraud
Judiciary Committee field trip meeting
there in New York City as Jim Jordan
attempts to obstruct Alvin Bragg's a
criminal investigation and Donald Trump
guess what it didn't do it didn't work
of course it didn't and Jim Jordan's a
professional rake stepper so it's not
it's not surprising that he ate rake
yesterday for sure and let them meet
rake as one of our great chant family
said hey guess what it's hat week it is
[__] em hat week we got Red Hats we got
gray hats we got Blue Hats it's [__]
them hat week here's what you do
you go to
hats.tonymichaels.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com click on the hat
store here's the promo code listen very
carefully hat week 10 the number 10 hat
week one zero hat week ten you go to the
Tony michaels.com click the hat store
link or go to
hats.dtonymichaels.com use the promo
code hat week 10 on all your hats you'll
get 10 off your entire hat order it's
only on the hats it's this week until
Sunday hat week 10 that's hat week one
zero at
hats.thedonymichaels.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com and click the Hat
Link store it's hat week speaking of
hands I got a cowboy hat here lurking in
the green room so let's do this let's go
to a break when we come back we'll have
Texas Paul with us uh we'll get Gabe
Sanchez in here
and uh we're gonna go over the stories
of the day of course but I have some I
am I have a great clip I want to show
you of Florida's Chief Financial Officer
okay this is his title Florida's Chief
Financial Officer basically says Disney
should be shaking in their boots
that Ron DeSantis is coming after the
nation not test him and not try him
because he's serious and he will take
them down like he did with their little
tax scheme nope didn't happen Ron is a
is a little [__] ass [__] and Mickey
Mouse is gonna stomp his ass stop a mud
hole in his ass everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
break
[Music]
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenteous lamb jams skull
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
here's Bob dear Bob I'm fixing to send
you some more of them Doritos you like
the red bag not the live love and blue
one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
come Buckle [__] a [__] em [__]
[__] to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome or welcome back to the show oh
stories
[Music]
can't make this [__] up I wish we could
we got Texas fall joining us this
morning Texas Paul good morning how are
you my friend
I'm wonderful Amigo happy to be here as
always yeah yeah I know you uh you
probably have a lot to say about the
news that's going on so oh yeah
you know what I
um this morning I I don't know if you
caught Donald Trump's uh little attack
on Ronda santis uh but he was attacking
oh Ronnie and I think I think um the
reason why is because Donald Trump
really he he doesn't have to be afraid
to lose his 10 12 uh of the manga base
you know 10 12 percent of the country's
gonna gonna back this guy no matter what
he does no matter how many criminal
judges I would imagine the 10 12 are
going to go to the primary polls uh and
vote for Donald Trump even if he's
sitting in a jail cell uh for for
violating a gag order I mean there's no
question about it
um Donald Trump has a solid cult base
they are a cult
um they have cult mentality and they're
not going to walk away from him and I
believe that's really what Ron DeSantis
is doing here and and Trump realizes
that
Trump realizes that Ron DeSantis can't
take his base away from him
um unless unless Trump allows him to
right he says oh go vote for Rhonda
Santas over me but he's not going to do
that so this morning
um Trump is leveling attacks against Ron
DeSantis attacks Disney I think they're
[__] stupid attacks Trump could do
much better than this there's way better
ways to attack Ron DeSantis but what
he's saying is is that Disney's gonna
leave Florida which is really [__]
stupid Disney's not gonna leave Florida
get the [__] out of here they've been
they've been there for almost 50 goddamn
years that they've had that theme park
there are at least started construction
on that theme park they're not going
anywhere I mean it's it's basically the
flagship of tourism in the State of
Florida I mean the reason why the State
of Florida has become known as tourism
other than the beaches is [__] Disney
World for Grant out loud so about 75
billion dollars a year right right
Disney is it going anywhere
so no matter what Trump says no matter
what Ron DeSantis does but yesterday let
me play this clip yesterday he stands in
front of a camera Rhonda Santas
oh man I just I can't even tell you how
because what he's trying to do
is he's trying to
um thumb his nose in the inspections of
the rides at Disney which Disney has an
impeccable record of the safety of their
rides because they take it very
seriously they spend a lot of [__]
money not just developing rides but
making sure those rides are safe because
if they're not safe that actually digs
into their pocket they don't give a [__]
what Ron DeSantis does it's it's the
safety and and and and their theme park
being being safe and a place of
inclusion that makes them profitable
like that's what that's your entire
business model so this idea that Disney
can't can't um do their the inspections
on their own this is just Ron DeSantis
trying to play big government with
Disney which Disney apparently and I'm
not sure exactly how it works but
apparently Disney gives these reports
over to other inspectors
um of where they have monitored their
safety inspections other rides but this
is a clip and he mentioned he brings up
prisons in this clip it's [__]
hilarious watch this
District you know one of the things they
tried to do was was put restrictive
covenants on the land that the district
owns So if you look at this whole
special district Walt Disney Corporation
obviously owns a lot of it but the
district owns other land you know quite
frankly I wasn't even thinking about
that land uh this was not something that
was really important one way or another
we just wanted them to live on the same
rules pay the debt pay the taxes all
that stuff oh but come to think of it
now people are like well there's what
should we do with this land and so you
know it's like okay kids I mean people
have said you know maybe maybe have
another maybe create a state park maybe
try to do more amusement parks uh
someone even said like maybe you need
another state prison who knows I mean I
just think that the possibilities are
are are endless and so that is now going
to be analyzed to see what would make
make the most sense okay so the
legitimate concern of of the state
saying hey we want to make sure that
Walt Disney because I think it is a
legitimate concern of the state of
Florida to say Walt Disney you need to
make sure you're inspecting your rides
properly we need to have oversight of
you inspecting your rides
that that that's a legitimate concern
but this idea that he instead of
building a state park or more Amusement
next to where the the highest percentage
of Tourism is brought money is brought
into the state he's like let's build a
prison and and then you then you
consider this is a children's theme park
it's hilarious right I mean just the
imagery is [__] dumb
well you know he sits there and he says
well the possibilities are endless well
let me just correct that right there Bob
Iger I've said this over and over again
the man is a knife fighter he is I'll
tell the audience tell the audience who
Bob Iger is Bob Iger used to be the CEO
of Disney way back when uh he fell out
of favor because he is so ruthless that
it actually started to actually taint
Disney's name a little bit so the board
stepped in and said Bob here's a nice
package go retire go away we're going to
bring in this nice guy uh he's going to
be the face of Disney from now on well
nice guy was there until November of
last year when Rhonda Santos started
picking fights with Disney and Disney
said you know what we need Bob Iger back
and they brought Bob Iger back and the
first thing Bob Iger did was he very
quietly with the Reedy Creek development
District uh passed a bunch of rules that
included a royal clause
um and it's it's contractually binding
the State of Florida signed this
agreement and it gives Disney veto power
over anything that this board or any
successor for as long as king Charles's
descendants are alive plus 21 years
and it's legally binding and it's a
common contractual practice throughout
Europe Canada you know you don't hear
about it much here in the U.S because we
don't cut into the Royals much but yeah
that was actually in the contract and
they signed it so
no the possibilities aren't endless the
only possibilities are what Disney wants
right that's it but that's why this is
so dumb is because of the imagery of it
that Rhonda santis is walking around
claiming he cares about children and
everything's about the safety and and
and for children have a great life and
blah blah that's why they gotta ban
books with the Statue of David him
that's why they got a band CRT to not
make white kids feel guilty about
slavery I mean on and on this [__]
goes but to stand there because I would
almost bet that Disney would entertain
the idea of a Florida State Park I I
would almost bet that they would
entertain that idea but the reason why
he brings up the state park and
amusement is because he wants he wants
Disney to believe that his next push is
to have a state prison next next to
Disney which is hilarious because if you
have a governor
and and you you you live in you live in
Texas so your Governors do not have
terms right your Governors can be
governor for for as long as they want as
long as they keep winning but in Florida
there's only two terms so if a Florida
Governor wants to build a prison then
they want that to be their Hallmark they
better start start that process in their
first year of their first term I don't
know if people know how hard it is to
get a state prison not even to start to
build it but even to get the state to
agree to put a state prison somewhere
it's a long [__] process it's years
in the making to figure out where you're
going to put it and how it's going to be
and what it's going to be built what
prisoners are going to be housed there
this is not an easy process so this is
all Ronda Santos blowing hot [__] air
and the reason why Texas ball is because
he has hatred for the lgbtq community
because the one thing that Disney did
other than what you're saying which was
basically put a veto on Rhonda Santos's
plan to get rid of the municipal tax
um um special district that they have so
that he could do whatever he wanted was
hey we're gonna have a pride Day [__]
and that was that and that's the thing
that really triggered that Rhonda Santos
here I think
well you know man I every time I listen
to these Republicans on any subject Visa
you know the Republican parties jumped
the shark they have jumped the shark
they really have I mean nobody's buying
this [__] anymore and every time I see
Ron DeSantis or Trump or anybody I
always think back to that you know the
Simpsons episodes with Sideshow Bob
stepping on a rake
I mean it's just over and over and over
they keep stepping on a rig to come out
and say oh you know that was the
stupidest most ham-handed thing he could
say because you know exactly what you're
talking about the practicality of it
isn't there but just think about the
Optics of it let's say he tries to do
this let's say he tries to express push
a prison there do you think the
Republican Party
of Florida which wants to survive and
knows that he you know Governor [__]
has term limits is going to have the
Optics
of putting a prison next to the single
greatest draw for children in the
country
I mean do you really think
that they're going to go along with this
this is the stupidest [__] I have ever
heard and that's all they do is say
stupid [__] one thing after another
after another just one stupid thing
after another and it never ends Tony it
never ends well and I don't I don't
think there's uh an end in sight when
they're doing this like they don't have
foresight to see exactly how this is
gonna play out I mean obviously his war
on wokism uh in Florida is not selling
around the country he I mean there's
there's cat turds that draw more flies
than Rhonda santis draws a crowd in Ohio
or anywhere else Jesus Christ he's in
Washington DC today to beg to cry like
Trump said oh please endorse me please
endorse me because these Florida
congressmen are endorsing Trump one
after another after another after
another the the um the Scooby-Doo gang
what's his name
um he endorsed the other day he's a nut
job he's the one that had the gun on on
on on his Zoom meeting when he was was
doing a hearing meeting and forget his
[__] name he's an [__] he's
supporting Trump so Rhonda Santos has to
go to D.C to gather up any kind of
support he can with Republican
Congressman because it's getting it's
getting to desperate hour here as he's
trying to prepare to run which I've been
telling Ron man I've been telling Ron
your window's closing man you need to
[__] resign your your governorship
and run man if you want to run you got
to do it now you can't wait until
Florida changes that law and you got to
do it now Gabe Sanchez is joining us
Gabe how are you today
um I want to play another clip while
we're uh as we bring Gabe in of another
Republican understanding why Ron
DeSantis is failing
um and really honestly I don't think
this Republican has any stake in it
other than he wants to be able to level
attacks on his likely opponents in 2028
uh Chris Christie here and actually
talks about how Ronda santis isn't a
conservative because of his war on
Disney listen to this I don't think Ron
DeSantis is a conservative based on his
access towards Disney I mean
you know where are we headed here now
um that if you express this agreement in
this country the government is allowed
to punish you
to me that's what I always thought
liberals did okay so first off [__] [__]
you Chris Christie that is not that is
not what liberals do liberalism is not
bread in in government punishing you
because you do or don't do something or
have of you or don't have of you I mean
um this goes back gave Sanchez to one of
the Twitter spaces we had the other day
about Ron DeSantis doing this uh six
six-week abortion ban he's Banning
abortion he's he's essentially banning
all abortion in the State of Florida I
mean it's gonna because you have to have
and then the exception well they weren't
they weren't happy with 15 weeks so then
they're right we have to go to six weeks
it's like right you know we we know we
know the path are going down which is
now as soon as you're you know where you
find out that you're pregnant or as soon
I mean who knows man after the point and
I joke here and obviously in hyperbole
but like it it is the realm of
possibility that as soon as you have sex
they know and they say okay you can't do
anything that's right that's the point
because they want but they've always
wanted that kind of government control
right and that's what this that's what
this Disney thing is so Chris Christie's
full of [__] and the reason why Chris
Christie's full of [__] because of true
liberal listen the new brand of
liberalism if you want to call it the
Tony Michaels brand of liberalism is
about [__] Freedom Liberty and choice
and my view is is that if a woman wants
to have the choice to have an abortion
she should have that if she wants to
have the choice to carry a dead fetus to
term no matter what no matter what uh
life is at risk her life her health I
don't give a [__] that's her [__]
Choice that's your choice you want if
you want to be a bigot be a [__]
bigot say it loud and proud for crying
out loud so we all can see so we know
who you are fine whatever if you want to
be inclusive in this country and you
want to make sure people have Liberty
equality and Equity then say that and we
can use we can use democracy and we can
use liberal democracy to do that so
Chris Christie's full of [__] here Texas
Paul when he says this is a tenement of
liberalism but I love the attack on Ron
DeSantis I have to admit Chris I can't
wait for you to attack Ron DeSantis more
so Texas ball what do you make or Chris
Christie's attack on Ron DeSantis here
but you know and and follow me it's
going to go first full circle I promise
you sure
um
there's a you know you've heard me talk
about it for them the Manhattan
Institute okay it's a really big [__]
deal it's a really big [__] deal it
is not like you know we're talking it's
a bigger deal than Heritage it's it
really is guys Alec going around writing
legislation they have come up with a
strategy and you can do a Google search
for Chris Ruffo he's a fellow at the he
was stupid enough to do an interview
he's a fellow at the Manhattan Institute
uh he's one of Ron desantis's buddy
Buddies
they've come up with a political
strategy of finding a villain
it used to be CRT now it's trans people
the the most important thing about the
villain has to be it can't be mainstream
and nobody can really know what it is
so the newest thing is trans people
right because let's be honest what did
any of us know about trans people
nothing really
you know nothing so they can say
anything they want that's why they came
out of the gate saying trans people are
groomers and pedophiles
you knew nothing about trans people you
kind of had a feeling that wasn't true
but
really what did you know you know and
their people jumped right on board
because you know like you keep saying
they're a cult they're a freaking cult
boss man said it we gotta say it you
know
so bring that back around to DeSantis he
is following
Chris Ruffo the Manhattan Institute
their guidelines and he wants to go
after trans people hot and heavy
Disney says no
and they're the tallest hog in the
trough in Florida
well what do you mean no
I gotta have everybody on board and and
and and so he went after Disney
then you turn around and you have the
same situation nobody who knew who Dylan
Mulvaney was did any of you know who
Dylan Mulvaney was not really no I
didn't you had to be able until they
freaked out yeah
yeah you had to be in a little circle in
tick tock where she was popular to know
who she was I had no idea I'm huge on
Tick Tock I had no idea who Dylan
Mulvaney was I'm glad she's out living
her best life
great
but we didn't bring Dylan milvaney into
your face just like you were talking
about earlier Tony find me a can with
her face on it you can't because
Anheuser-Busch didn't didn't Mass
distribute Dylan Mulvaney pictures
there's just a sub there it's capitalism
there's a subset of the country that is
lgbtq and Anheuser-Busch wants to sell
him beer
so they did this nobody put this in John
Rich's face you all know who John Rich
were Big and Rich you know you know you
mean bigot and Rich
actually big and he's not that he's not
that crazy like Johnny that's why
they're really not together that much
anymore but uh John Rich who's out there
talking about I'm sick of y'all putting
this in my face
these are the people like so just to
give a quick context I uh I did a video
uh for what was that on the the guy
Webster Barnaby the Florida state
representative who went on this intense
transphobic rant to talk about how trans
people are mutants and demons and imps
right he doubled down he was like look
you can fight me on it it's a battle I'm
gonna win so yesterday I made that video
public right so I you know I really
listen to the people on patreon first
and then yesterday I was like great it's
gonna go live for the public
and it wasn't until like maybe six hours
into the video or like into it being
public did
the transphobes come out and holy [__]
the amount of com I mean like some of
them are still up and some of them got
flagged automatically and some of them I
was like no we're not going to say that
on here I'm not gonna allow it and those
people can come at me and be like Oh
Free Speech there's a difference between
free speech and hate speech so the
things that people were saying I was
like I'm not gonna [__] put up with
this but the amount of things that they
said
despite the fact I was like here's data
here's studies the actual perpetrator
this fear that you have about a dude
going into a bathroom isn't a dude with
a wig on and a dress it's a guy that
goes into the bathroom and commits this
right the idea it's it goes back to the
idea that like oh we have to attack
trans people because trans people are
the ones who trying to walk in the
locker rooms and take over women's
sports the idea that you would assume
that somebody would just hey you know
what I'm going to start taking hormones
and change my body and my appearance
just so I can win some sort of sports
like game or match or whatever it might
be swimming or whatever it could be
right they're trying to come up with
some excuse to be like oh well I'm not
good enough because of this and I need a
reason to hate this group and the same
is to be said for these people online
right and to your point about this
Manhattan Institute and saying like how
they're pushing this narrative and
people are just accepting it blindly
right and and so I saw these kind
comments last night and I was like oh my
God this is [__] insane because it's
not only people like oh do what you want
to do just just don't put that on me
there's a lot of those comments but then
there were some comments where like I
dare someone to walk into the bathroom
and I'm like I guess you'd actually be
fighting the dude who's committing
sexual assault it's a straight male
who's committing these these acts of
violence against other people it's not
trans people it's not a trans woman
who's going into a bathroom thinking you
know what I want to do today I want to
assault someone else
no the battery the assault the sexual
assault those are all acts that are done
by men right so you see people like
Manhattan or you know whoever it might
be Ron DeSantis or the Russell
Republican party try to create a
scapegoat for their own problem right
it's their group their group is the one
that are committing these these acts of
violence against other people and
they're now trying to be like well it's
like the guns right it's not the guns
that are the problem right it's not the
straight men that are committing the
assault and these crimes it's this other
thing right it's this Boogeyman it's
this monster like we can't we can't let
them into society and so it's just like
it the Not only was that guy just
completely vitriolic in his rant the
types of comments I saw last night very
very aligned with what you're talking
about now which is like no no doubt no
question as to when when you hear these
things these people just accept it
blindly and say ah yes that is the
narrative I'm gonna take and you can
present all the facts and the study and
the data to me and I will not accept
anything you have to say except that
trans people bad you know like it's it's
it's disheartening and it's it's
disgusting
and where this ties into your question
Tony with Chris Christie that you were
posing to me is
inbev Anheuser-Busch donates a metric
[__] ton of money to the Republican
party right specifically to the Missouri
Republican party because they died in
Missouri yeah yeah I talked about the
other day
Disney has 8.5
billion dollars in cash on hand cash net
worth is over 200 million Ron DeSantis
is wait how much eight how much did you
say thousand five
is fighting a capitalist organization
who not only holds some of the greatest
profit producing Assets in the world
like Star Wars and the Marvel movies but
you're saying they have eight billion
dollars in cash and Rhonda Santos almost
nine with these [__] almost
nice and get this just for comparison
just for comparison Paul singer the guy
that's the the the real money bags that
that's the chairman of the Manhattan
Institute is worth 5.5 billion total all
assets everything 5.5 billion this is
the guy that's making Ron DeSantis puff
his chest out because he thinks he's a
big dog
Disney could literally Crush Paul singer
with Brinks trucks falling from the sky
you know I wouldn't phase it
the ticket sales well speaking of that
that's why Chris Christie what you're
asking is just just wrap that up that's
why Chris Christie is he's looking at
this saying
[__] no we're not going down this road I
mean I get your strategy but you're
[__] with our money you know I mean
pardon my language and that's why Chris
Christie's really out there language are
you want to do what the hell are you
talking about
pardon your lane get the language out
lay it down on the table Texas So
speaking of finances this morning on Fox
News not only is Ron DeSantis leveling
attacks against Disney but the Florida's
Chief Financial Officer Jimmy pateronis
I think his name is this [__] guy
this guy I saw this you just you just
said Disney has nine billion dollars to
pile on top of these [__] now
this guy is supposed to be the listen to
the title Chief Financial Officer so
this guy's supposed to know something
about Finance I guess and I can't say it
enough Tony
that's cash right that's not assets
that's literally the checkbook has nine
billion dollars Gabe can you look up how
much Disney paid for Star Wars and
Marvel how much they paid for it can you
see what they paid for that and then how
much they paid for Fox I don't know if
people know that but they bought 20
years so Disney in 2012 Disney paid
4.05 billion dollars for lucasfilm God
damn in the in the form of cash in stock
so and then with with 1.8 wait wait wait
wait wait so they took cash out of their
little stockpile that they had to beat
the Ron desantises in the world and
they're like you know what for the at
this point let's just buy lucasfilms
which is Star Wars which is one of the
most profitable franchises of all time
okay so how much do they pay for only
and not only not only that but you also
have to remember like what what George
Lucas created like all the CGI that we
had today the tech technology all from
his Digital Arts company right so who
owns that what who owns that who owns
all that technology
I mean one one might say that it's uh
it's does the mouse own it does the
mouse it's the house of mouse
the house of mouse you know how many
contracts that uh industrial Light and
Magic does for other movies right that
are outside Disney's perfume they when
just for anyone who watches a movie
we're like hey look at all these special
effects wait till the credits roll
Disney did it look look at look at
industrial Light Magic
look at the list of people anime I have
I have a friend who works at industrial
Light Magic and she's like oh yeah I can
tell you right now she was like I worked
on uh uh she worked on one of the I
think it was Rogue one and she was like
just to tell you how many people work on
something she's like I was a part of
three people a team of three people that
worked on the shading of Princess Leia's
face at the end of the movie okay three
[__] one one small team worked
on just the shade 15 seconds like 15
seconds super super small just so when
whenever someone goes to a movie and
they're like hey look at all the special
effects just wait because I can tell you
nine times out of ten if not all of the
time it's going to be industrial line
magic ilm that is working behind the
scenes for a movie that has nothing to
do with Star Wars so let me ask you what
did they pay for Marvel okay all right
so well here it's so it's it was 4.05
billion in the form of cash in stock
with 1 0.855 billion in stock which
means that the remaining 2.2 billion to
get there was in cash okay so that's
what they did and then if I go to uh
let's see why you look that up let me
let me throw a plug out for Bob Iger
again and how well he's been handling
this let's get Bob on the show hell why
not I know [__] four billion that guy
that guy you know because remember the
goal is to politicize everything which
means they need somebody to fight back
fail miserably with Bud Light nobody was
out there defending Bud Light ooh let's
go go drink Bud Light you know there was
no other guy for them to fight with
Disney has done that
masterfully they say nothing they
address tiny D in no [__] way they're
like who
of which we dictate what he's gonna do
about our Municipal land grants isn't
that the guy that Parks our cars I mean
did you know that Rhonda santis got
married at Disney did you know that yeah
it makes it
married there okay I'm gonna see paper
Marvel how much they paid 4 billion okay
so we're about the same cash money or
stock
say if it was Cash Money four billion
okay did you see that Meme going around
with Ron DeSantis walking with his two
girls in little pink dresses it's a real
picture of him from behind at Disney or
like pardon me not at Disney they're
walking by a train they're walking by
train but it's not at Disney and the
little girl says on the left says daddy
why can't we go to Disneyland and the
little girl on the right says because
our dad's a prick
anyway this is his [__] title and
he's saying this [__] about wait you
can't believe I don't know well I have
to assume then everything in this world
is totally believable because it's
it's a Republican party right it's it's
totally on brand it's it's like a baby
but old Jimmy here yeah
okay Patronus by the way
um which is a oh it's a Warner Brothers
property obviously he's Harry Potter but
whenever I hear Patronus I think of
Harry Potter right like I wave my wallet
oh Patronus right like that's what I
think of when I hear this guy's name so
right out of the gate I can't take him
seriously I think he's made up I think
he's just well I think well he's gonna
make this real he's gonna make some [__]
up here listen to what he makes up here
this is this is [__] hilarious the
the going on Fox News to try to make Ron
DeSantis look tough this is [__]
hilarious Disney should be working
around the clock to go and make amends
with Rhonda
Disney and Bob Iger should be working
around the clock like they should be
doing nothing don't worry about the
trash don't worry about making sure to
inspect the rides don't worry about the
movies you're making and all the money
that you're going to be making for the
movies and the [__] entertainment
that you produce you need to be making
sure that Rhonda santis your dictator
and King in Florida you're going to be
pleasing him get the [__] out of here
you know who he reminds me of he reminds
me of um
uh Devin Nunes and Devin Nunez being in
in running around me like oh well these
other people should be super afraid of
Donald Trump because Donald Trump is
going to own all of them he's like and
just wait Twitter Twitter's shaking in
her boots because we've got a true true
social
well he goes on he goes on Texas ball uh
let me play the rest of the clip and
then I'll let you uh dig into Jimmy here
because this is it gets even better
after this
is you know does Bob Iger ever reach out
do you have any sense of what their
direction is here
well look if I'm Bob Iger I am working
around the clock to try to figure out
how to make amends with Rhonda Sands
just like Bud Light should be working
around the clock
need to be addressed it is wide open
I'd like this
you know what Bud Light did Bud Light
did I know what I know what they
delivered to Kid Rock's Bar in Nashville
Bud Light Bud Light yeah [__] bar
they picked up the phone and called
little Ronaldo Romney McDaniel and told
her
look nothing personal but every dollar
in sales we lose in Bud Light because
you're [__] comes out of your
political contribution that's right and
then all of a sudden deleted that tweet
real quick well Don Jr Don Jr I think's
done two or three rants on his stupid
[__] show triggered which you think
he'd be triggered by this Bud Light
thing not but he's went on his show
triggered and said stop with the Bud
Light stuff stop with that [__] yeah you
[__] they pay they give my dad
money okay we need that money to survive
you sons of [__]
they are they are beholden to these
corporate companies like that's the
other problem too like Republicans want
to talk about how you know capitalism is
great and corporate influence is great
and all this stuff but as soon as they
want to you know snap back at a company
for something that you know like
supporting lgbtq Community right it's
crazy uh something the company never put
it in their face or right had them be a
part of or yeah they didn't force it on
anyone they've been doing it you know
they partnered with glad for over two
decades Coors Light has been working
since 1978 supporting the lgbtq
community like it's a losing bet it's an
uphill losing battle for Republicans but
what they don't realize is when they go
after these corporate companies that
they in the moment they're like like
knee-jerk reaction is to go after them
right because we got to own the libs but
then they don't remember that the people
giving them money are those very same
corporate companies so they're like oh
oh [__] okay uh okay the Well's gonna
dry up soon we gotta like we gotta do a
180 and go back home we can't say
anything bad anymore and we gotta then
position it as
oh it's not that we're giving up but
it's for some other you know [__]
reason and Don Jr yeah the exact same
thing
I just Googled real quick because you
know it's it's growing because like in
my generation if you were gay you
suffered physical and emotional abuse
you did
that's not happening anymore we we gen
xers started to put an end to that [__]
and every generation following has been
better and better about it so more and
more people are coming out and saying
yeah I'm lgbtq because it's not as
painful
right now we're up to 10 percent of the
population
our lgbtq and it's more than that you
know who knows that
[__] Anheuser-Busch knows that you
damn right and they want to sell that 10
of the population beer
we want to do that Texas Paul [__]
capitalism or some crazy idea like that
motive or some [__] well here's here's
the other thing too
um about like the the the beer thing
right
um because the statement from the CEO of
Anheuser-Busch was weak as [__] I can't
even believe they they let him put that
out on social media to be quite honest
it was just word salad is all it was
because it was trying to appease both
sides but to be frank with you and I
know this is probably going to piss off
some of the audience members liberals do
the same stupid [__] the left does the
same stupid [__] where they think they
can take down a company I mean you might
be able to put them in their place right
by letting them know what the masses
want but they did this stupid [__] with
Spotify with Joe Rogan do you remember
this this was last year and people were
telling me to go off Spotify I said [__]
you I'm not going on Spotify I'm not
gonna go off Spotify where my voice can
be heard to an audience piss on you I'll
speak against Spotify I'll speak against
Joe Rogan and the other [__] creators
on Spotify that are pieces of garbage
but I'm not gonna leave Spotify so you
can't hear my voice [__] that use your
goddamn microphone use your free speech
because it's ridiculous you use your
feet in the economy and I know a lot of
the life doesn't like capitalism but
folks capitalism is a form of voting I
don't know if you know that it is a form
of voting and when when someone like Kid
Rock tries to tries to invoke
um people voting against Bud Light but
he does it in the way that he did it
right because this Chief Financial
Officer this dumb [__] Jimmy who works
for Ron DeSantis he's dumber than
[__] Ron DeSantis to think that Bud
Light is going to come crawling begging
to to Kid Rock because he purchased
eight cases of Bud Light and he shot
them the [__] and at the same point he's
selling [__] Bud Light down in his
bar in Nashville to his [__] fans on
a building that's got his [__] name
on it [__] him Bud Light doesn't give us
[__] about Kid Rock or what Kid Rock
says the only thing Bud Light cares
about is what Texas Paul is saying
selling beer that's that that's their
only [__] thing they want to do if
they do charity work it's to sell beer
it's the pr themselves why do you think
[__] Bud Light spends millions of
dollars in commercials every year at the
Super Bowl when
honestly everyone knows who [__]
Budweiser is why do they have to do that
the reason why is because they know it
sells beer that's what they know did you
hear desantises [__] up on that notion I
mean when he would when he was asked
about Bud Light a Guinness get us
Guinness is the most supportive of all
the beer companies Guinness is like oi
oi bring your fabulous ass over here and
have a point you know I mean they they
are the most supportive and because
because Ron DeSantis is a [__] [__]
it doesn't know I I he doesn't even
understand his own [__] hate sister
well I won't drink Bud Light anymore
ever you know and they're like well what
beer do you like and he's like oh [__] I
don't drink beer I don't I don't I don't
know anything about it uh Guinness
Guinness again this is the sparkliest
[__] supporter there is out there man
you know what I will say I I I I I am
I'm gonna back up a bit because I would
imagine that Guinness's
um Main that main focus is not exactly
beer sales but it is to drink beer like
that like like that is the ultimate that
is the ultimate thing that leads them to
the beer sales but Guinness is like no
we just want people to drink [__]
beer okay and we want them to drink dark
beer that's what we want them drink so
yes of course Ron DeSantis Falls
straight into this trap all these
fascists do here's an example this
morning of Donald Trump attacking he
he's he shortened his name to desanctus
the Sanctus the Sanctus
okay well hold on I'm gonna put this out
there okay the new name that on April
18th at 10 06 a.m Pacific time the new
name it's going to come down to is
desanis desanis because yeah
you think so is that like a uh homophobe
type thing is that what he's doing I
mean is that what he's already he's
already made he's already made a
homophobic type uh like little hit at
Ron DeSantis about the whole being a
pedophile towards younger women possibly
men right so yeah because he was like
women definitely and maybe maybe maybe
dudes I don't know right which I don't
care what Rhonda Santos's sexual
orientation is I really don't give a
[__] but I hope Rhonda I hope uh Donald
Trump keeps attacking him text ball you
had something
oh man I had a guy he said attack me do
you know I'm racist do you know I'm
racist yeah I'm racist against Italian
people dude accordingly according to
Italian people so you hate Italians huh
this Maga guy
comes on to my Twitter feed and starts
just having a [__] meltdown that I'm
a racist because I called Ron meatball
run
so he really was so dumbfounded that he
had no [__] clue where meatball Ron
came from
that I couldn't respond I was just like
does he love everything that Trump says
yeah because he loves Trump I'm sure oh
my God that's hilarious well I was like
I was literally speechless guys
I didn't know what to say I was like
wow you know I mean there's gonna be so
many nicknames for Ron DeSantis and
really I think that's probably going to
be his greatest downfall here is because
that's one thing they do not know how to
deal with like Republicans absolute and
we saw it in 2016 when when Trump was in
the primary with these [__]
they had no idea how to handle it they
didn't know that they should call him
names back they didn't know that like
they didn't understand that's what they
should do that's why I call them the
Cheeto dust q and honor Grandpa
Poopypants you know yeah you you gotta
you gotta do it back and the reason
that's a bully in the mouth that's right
that's right if if they're gonna do it
they can't handle it so they didn't
understand that but here he is giving
him a new moniker Des Sanctus okay Des
Sanctus is being absolutely destroyed by
Disney which is true I cannot believe
Donald Trump typed out something on true
social that is actually true but he did
the original PR plan fizzled so now he's
going back with a new one in order to
save face which also is true hey man
we're getting somewhere with Grandpa
boopy pants here now here's where it
start the cheese starts to slide off the
cracker Texas spawn game here's where it
starts to take a nosedive here Disney's
next move will be to announce that no
more money will be invested in Florida
because of the governor that is such
[__] Disney is not gonna do any of
that they're not gonna say like you said
earlier Texas fall they're not going to
say anything about [__] meatball
pudding fingers tiny D Rhonda santis
they're not going to do it they're not
he says in fact they could even announce
a slow withdrawal or sale of certain
properties you heard such he's such he's
such a [__] I mean I know what
he's trying to do here what he's trying
to do here is he's trying to put this
out in the ethos so his [__]
supporters will start saying this [__]
right and then everyone will start to
believe that Disney World is going to
leave Florida right yeah that's that's
what he wants his [__] cult to
believe so that's what he's doing here
so he finishes up here and again it gets
better he said watch that would be a
killer in the meantime this is all so
unnecessary a political stunt Ron should
work on squatter mess what the [__] does
any of that mean at the end what the
hell does that mean I I have no idea I
mean like you you also have to keep in
mind that this is the same dude who told
everyone that Mar-A-Lago was getting
searched by the FBI the same guy who
said he was going to be arrested on a
Tuesday which he did it just took two
weeks for it to happen the same guy
who's talking about you know Disney
World leaving the guy the guy speaks
or or yells into this Echo chamber on
Truth social
to get you know acknowledgment and and
validation from his group
when he tries to say these things right
he wants to come up with a bunch of [__]
that someone's going to talk about
they're going to wonder uh you know
they're gonna they're gonna be like oh
well well this is you know this is
actually going to happen because Donald
Trump said it was going to happen well
it's like these things don't happen
unless Donald Trump mentions like oh I'm
the victim I'm the person and in this
regard right here he's talking about how
Disney World not and here's the thing
not to say that Disney could not just up
and move and say yeah we're going to go
to Montana or something like that like
they have the money and the resources to
build a whole new uh amusement park
right but they're not going to do that
right they have their roots are in
Florida and there is no economic way
that they would ever decide that they're
gonna pick up and move like their
[__] traveling circus okay not gonna
happen and not only then
but if they leave you have to imagine
not that it's going to happen but you'd
have to imagine the utter [__] show that
would follow you have a total loss in
jobs a total off in revenue from tourism
you have a total loss in uh and property
value and and taxes that are paid you
now have this huge mass of land that's
just abandoned right and that no one's
going to take over you you would have to
be [__] insane to ever think that you
could pick up and move a whole Disney
World amusement park to another state or
city or wherever in the U.S it's the
dumbest thing that you would ever see
they're never going to do it Donald
Trump bitching and moaning about how
he's gonna Rhonda said he's gonna cause
it to happen is insane because it's it's
just something that is a complete lie it
doesn't make any sense it doesn't bet
doesn't benefit anyone involved and like
I said Disney's gonna be there for a
long haul they've been there for 50
years and Ronda santis is only there for
three years plus now uh Texas Paul have
you been to Disney World have you been
there
you're muted
sorry sorry took the grandkids yeah
okay so amazing Place have you been to
Disneyland
in California no okay so do you know the
story of Walt Disney why he built
Disneyland
why do you build Disneyland
Disney World but well that's what was my
next question did you know why he built
Disney World yeah because they got no
customers from east of the Mississippi
so they knew they needed a place
on that side of the country do you know
Howie do you know how he bought all that
land before Disney World do you know how
he bought it
um no I don't I mean I borrowed the [__]
out of money Roy Disney Roy Disney who
is actually the brains behind the
financial operation of Disney the reason
why Disney exists today and the reason
why Disney has got piles of cash and
they can pay 4 billion for Marvel 4
billion uh for for lucasfilms the reason
why is because of Roy Disney Roy Disney
was the brains behind Disney
Walt Disney was the creative mind he was
the one that made it look the way it
looked he made the music the way he was
he was such an integral part of the art
of it but Roy Disney was the one who
financed the whole thing without Roy
Disney Walt Disney wouldn't wouldn't
have done what he did now what Roy
Disney did is Roy Disney went down to
Florida under under the the the you know
operation of Walt Disney because Walt
Disney had a dream of building a future
city which is Epcot today which that's
not what it turned out to be but that
was his dream and what Walt Disney
wanted to do is he wanted to buy as much
land as possible
and the reason why I want to buy as much
land as possible is because he he was
actually uh he was limited to what
Disneyland could be because he was
landlocked where Disneyland is in
California but in Florida he wanted on
as much land as he possibly could and
when they went there to buy it no one
knew who was buying this they would buy
it under shell companies and llc's they
were doing it very secretively and the
reason why is because they didn't want
people to know that Disney was buying up
all this land Walt didn't and Roy didn't
want them to know that it's so that
people wouldn't start buying up Parcels
all around them they wanted to be a
buyout all this land that had this huge
swath of land to build this future and
it was [__] land too it was swamp plants
that's why that's why he that's why they
picked it is because they knew they
could buy as much as possible no one
would know the difference they can end
up buying all this land and not being
landlocked and be able to create an
entire future city it was kind of the
original idea and then Disney World came
in now and do you know how long it took
for Disney World build from the from
when it started to what it is now
he's only a few years it was only a few
years well they they have built over
over the last five decades they built
not just Disney World but they built
Epcot they built the the animal kingdom
they I mean if you go to Disney there's
like and they're like five or six Parks
now I mean it's been it's been 20 years
since I've been to Disney or more I
think I went when I was a teenager I
haven't been since
um but but but I mean when I went 20
years ago there was like five parks on
the Disney property now the point that
I'm trying to make here is that this
idea
that [__] Disney not only is gonna
pack up and move somewhere where the
[__] are they gonna move like where are
they gonna pack up their park and move
and the other thing too is the
infrastructure there for the economy is
already in place and Florida can't give
that up Disney knows that Florida knows
that what we're gonna say Texas ball I
agree with you that they're not going to
move they're not going to have to move
or anything like that right but they
absolutely could move I I disagree with
you there they could most likely go
somewhere It's a Small World The Teacup
ride all that was built in the in the
50s and the 60s those rides are are 50
60 years old the newest rides they've
only built like two maybe three new
rides in the last decade
everything there is incredibly old has
been has been monetized out
they can rip it down and move it to
Georgia if they have to they can they
can do you know do you know how many
jobs
uh
uh that are created by Disney World
you mean you mean like the the economy
of Disney World yeah I know they bring
in 75 to 78 billion dollars a year but I
don't know how many exact jobs so in in
Disneyland so uh for I'll start with
Disneyland Disneyland It's 60. I just
want to make sure I get this remember
right it is uh according to a report in
UH 60
5 700 jobs and again this is chosen five
so there's plenty more from there the
Disneyland Resort including about 20 000
direct Disney employees in 3 800
third-party employees so 65 700
including 20 000 direct employees and 38
3800 third-party contractors that's just
Disneyland okay that's not different
Disney World no no no that's Disneyland
California yeah I want to set it up okay
so then
before you talk about Burbank the
studios in Burbank and all the other
stuff that's just exactly okay the art
development side that's just it if we go
to uh Disney World which covers 25 000
Acres okay that's 39 square miles that
we've been talking about
that's how big uh that they have right
um
they offer right now the number of
employees at Disney World Walt Disney
World 77
000 plus over 77
000 people are employed by the house of
mouse in the Disney World and Ron
DeSantis is saying uh we don't want
those jobs [__] and this guy over here
is trying to joke about how there's a
property next to Disney World where he's
like maybe we'll open up a State
Penitentiary
the guy cannot read a room it's like sit
down shut up and just take the beating
that you're gonna take and don't ever
open your mouth again against Walt
Disney because what you're gonna do is
you're gonna isolate yourself you are
the Walt Disney is already or uh Rhonda
Santos is already losing billionaire
donors that would back his presidential
campaign just on his policies alone
this guy now wants to double down and
say you know what we should do we should
open up an eyesore that's a State
Penitentiary that's next door to Walt
Disney World
uh okay I mean good luck with that but I
have a hard time believing that one
you'd actually follow through with it
because you're a [__] ass [__] and two
anyone who also most likely puts money
into Walt Disney right because I I can
only assume that the people who would be
back in Ron DeSantis in Florida are also
somehow invested in Disney
so the idea that
he would ever try to do this I feel like
he's going to completely backfire oh it
already is yeah it is it already is yeah
it already is background but I would be
derelict in my duty
um because I want to move on to another
Donald Trump statement about another uh
[__] ass [__] that he made this
morning
um our favorite Elon Musk but I would be
derelict in my duty if I did not bring
up the other war that Ron DeSantis is
waging in the State of Florida
um it's a war on women and women's right
to their [__] health care and their
bodily autonomy so Ronda santis signed
one of the most restrictive Women's
Health bills and that's what it is
[__] we need to stop saying the
[__] word abortion we just need to
stop saying it it is [__] Health Care
these stupid bastards don't even know
what abortion services are when when I
was in that Twitter space these people
are acting like any anything that's an
abortion service is is somehow a doctor
taking a butcher knife and chopping a
baby up in pieces after it's been
you know they're like oh well we got you
know they were like oh well abortions
are just a trendy thing to do and people
who go to Planned Parenthood are only
getting abortions like we're just going
to completely and I was like look man
even if you remove the abortions and you
just had sex education and you had
things and resources for new parents
right or single mothers or whatever it
might be you guys still want to defund
it you guys even if I were to say you
know what abortion is completely off the
table as a service that's offered to
people at planned hair Planned
Parenthood
you would still say defund and get rid
of Planned Parenthood so I hate I there
are like so few things in this world I
hate but when you attack women's rights
and you say oh well you know abortion
shouldn't be legal okay if that's the
way that you feel then you better
[__] guarantee that you have a backup
plan on how you're going to offer
services and education instability in a
in a resource Community for these women
and men who are who are the the the
fathers or the or the husbands in this
situation you better have a [__]
backup plan on how you're gonna if
you're gonna defund this organization
then you better have the resources then
say you know what we're going to fund
and invest this alternative to make sure
that women have the resources the food
the care the support that they need
emotional physical like whatever it
might be you better you better guarantee
that you have something that is is equal
if not better if you're going to go
against all of these people and say you
know what we're going to remove this
this total service from the economy well
I doubt they're gonna no they won't and
anytime you ask them they're like well
of course I of course I support that and
they're like oh well the State of the
State of Florida wants to put 25 million
25 million do you know how quickly 25
million is going to get [__] snatched
up on all these other things that are
going to be used for give me a [__]
break
what did you eat for breakfast this
morning Gabe uh I haven't even had
breakfast
that's what you need to do every [__]
day Gabe is on
fire I mean damn Amen brother amen I'm
tired of this [__] I am with you I
am [__] with you I am not having a
conversation about when we should make
abortion illegal I'm having a
conversation about who [__] decides
whether there's an abortion or not
that's the debate I'm having I you know
screw these [__] in their six weeks
15 weeks whatever I don't give a [__]
you know my wife and I were just talking
about a woman the other day that she was
at 26 weeks
she was having a horrible pregnancy
she went into complications they took
the child at 26 weeks the child has
horrendous problems they have eight
[__] children eight
all you know including this child that
now has horrific health problems because
she was taking it at 26 weeks and the
mother died went on to have
complications and died a couple weeks
later
now we have eight kids with no [__]
mom
and a single dad trying to raise all of
these children plus a child that has all
of these complications
I'm sorry folks I don't give a damn how
you feel about it but the best thing for
the eighth you know the seven living
children was for that mom to have had an
abortion when the complications started
and I don't care if it was 20 weeks I
don't care if it was 25 weeks sometimes
if you want to call it a baby fine
people die in this world they do this
notion of like cops always have to go
home at the end of the day no sometimes
cops die on their job that is what
they're supposed to do they're supposed
to charge into the school where the guy
has the [__] AR-15
you know I mean this this notion that
everybody has to live no that that's not
reality folks sometimes in this world
for the best result to happen somebody
needs to die and that baby
should have died and that mother should
have lived that was the best outcome and
that's that is I think that's the core
of the problem with the Republican party
is they make claims that they're
pro-life right we're pro-life we're
pro-life we care you know we care about
the kids right all the stuff well the
kid can't live right or the kid can't be
healthy without let's just call what it
is right like the mother in that
situation is is the host of of this new
life and is is is giving that that child
nutrients right but if the if the mother
is unhealthy and the kid won't do well
right but in this sense of like if the
kid or the baby or whatever you want to
call at that stage is not healthy and is
now causing detrimental harm to the
mother's health right that there's no
guarantee it's one of those things may
say in this situation
who are we pro-life for right are we
pro-life for the mother like if you want
to say you know because Republicans want
to say oh well the the purpose of of
women are to to Bear children right
that's their sole purpose as as
regressive as that ideology is they want
to say the mother's purpose is to have
children well that person can't have any
more kids if you don't take care of that
woman right so when they say oh we're
pro-life we're pro-life well you're not
pro-life like [__] man even when you
look at the shooting in Louisville they
were like oh you know what giving blood
donating blood that's too political
none of these people are pro-life none
of them are pro-life they do not care
about human life they care about you
know a fetus or you know whatever in
terms of that but they're like great
another one popped out we don't care
about the mother we don't care about the
life we don't care about the the the
detrimental harmful effects that are
gonna be lasting in that family right
we're not pro-life [__] if we don't
really care about them after the mother
dies and that's how life goes Republican
party is now pro-life in any way shape
or form right they want to they want to
protect this and protect that but they
abandon it Tony they don't care yeah
yeah Tony you mind if I jump in after
this because I mean filibuster here I'm
sorry wait they [__] know this they
know this this is that same [__] of
abortion is people don't know men don't
know what the [__] abortion is it's a
something you don't know about so they
can say any [__] thing about it and
just lie their asses off and you know
they they show you pictures of six weeks
old fetuses where the [__] feet run
down into the legs of the mother because
the fetus is goddamn three feet tall I
mean it's it's it's crazy [__] and they
[__] know it and you know how you can
prove it just a [__] Duggar Jessa
Duggar when she started having health
problems she went and had a [__]
abortion
that's what happened
they didn't do this [__] when it was
their own you know the Duggars are the
world's worst pushing this Christianity
[__]
narrative about all babies are sacred
this and the other [__] when it was
one of their own go get that [__]
abortion Jess and make sure you're okay
which is the right thing to do I am not
hating on Jessa Duggar she did the right
[__] thing
she did but everybody in the country
should have that same damn right and
they know it they [__] know it
um so Ron DeSantis passes this bill to
restrict Women's Health Care and again
I think we should stop using the word
abortion we should just call it women's
health care because that's what it is
because not every single service that is
an abortion service is what these people
are thinking and let me tell you
something pro-lifers care about life
they care about their own lives just
like in the Jessa Duggar situation where
she cares about her own life do you
think you think for a goddamn second
that rich women in Florida are gonna
have be restricted for for [__]
abortion service hell to the no they're
not hell to the no it's already women
who struggle with buying health care
services and access to health care
services in the first place that are
going to be restricted to Health Care
within six weeks of their [__]
pregnancy you and and again you know
what the thing that really pisses me off
about the debate of of women's health
care and specifically around this
abortion Services is that there's I mean
right now we got three dudes talking
about this right right we got three
dudes talking about women's health care
which we're advocates for Women's Health
Care but time for the woman's choice and
that's where my [__] that I'm for the
woman's choice right I don't give a [__]
listen if if Jesse Duggar wanted to
carry that baby to full term and die
have at it have at it Jessa have the
[__] at it that is your choice that is
your [__] Liberty as a person who
wants to do what they want to do with
their [__] bodily autonomy and their
health care decisions that is between
Jessa Duggar and her doctor she wants to
die the woman who had eight children
that's her right to [__] die if she
wants to just like it's the right of any
other [__] woman to receive health
care services and it's none of your
[__] business Rhonda santis or any
other wrinkly old [__] ball sack of a
republican man stay the [__] out of
Women's Health Care choices that's all I
give a [__] about when you're talking
about abortion Services it's women's
health care it's theirs it's their
bodily autonomy it's between them and
their [__] doctor the government
should keep their [__] nose out of it
now
just like any other [__] institution
in this country or any other kind of
service that has provided to the public
in Mass the government has the right to
make sure those Services the health care
services are provided to that woman in a
safe and decent manner just like we had
the right to regulate [__] guns so we
have a deuce a safe and decent manner in
our country so I love when [__]
come at me you're like oh well you don't
want the government and women's body but
you want to regulate guns I'm not saying
I don't want to regulate Women's Health
Care it should be safe and decent you
and and readily accessible just like our
safety from guns should be readily
accessible to us we should not have to
run around fearing to be [__] shot up
by a bunch of bullets because anybody
and everyone wants to own a [__]
weapon of War we as the government get
to decide of what regulations are going
to dictate safety and decency in those
markets so I think that Ron DeSantis
should take that pin that he signed that
[__] restriction of women's health
care he should take that pin and shove
it straight up his [__] ass that
[__] and and I was in a Twitter
space with the son of a [__] that was
standing 10 foot from that [__]
10 feet he's in the picture I don't know
it's John something another he's a
[__] idiot he's a [__] liar he's a
[__] gaslighter he claims he claims
and I I if you'll find his name for me
Gabe because I don't want to just call
him John that [__] he he lied in
that [__] Twitter space when he said
the only thing that Planned Parenthood
does is provide abortions and that's
[__] that's a hundred percent
[__] [__] and and Planned
Parenthood is is more pro-life than any
[__] Pro adoption forced birth agency
out there you [__] my wife my
wife went to Planned Parenthood to get
her for IUD removed so we could have our
daughter
she went to Planned Parenthood so she
could get pregnant you [__] phonies
that [__] I don't know what that John
guy's name is but I ate his ass in that
Twitter space that [__] saying
that Planned Parenthood is is only the a
murder institution you son of a [__]
I'm telling you I'm telling you the
battle to be fought is for Women's
Health Care and they're ready to [__]
John stenberger yeah sure [__] him if
that's him
husband father attorney
could take his Christianity and he can
stick it right where Ron stuck his
[__] pin straight up his [__] ass
that [__] lying ass [__]
lying about women's health care to
restrict the access that women have the
health care in some communities the only
access that that that underprivileged
women poor women single moms have in
these communities to health care at all
is that [__] Planned Parenthood
clinic and the only reason why is
because Planned Parenthood supports
Women's Health cares women's rights and
their choice and their [__] decisions
they want to make about their body and
their bodily autonomy so you Ron
DeSantis and you John whatever the [__]
your name is you stay the [__] out of it
I'm sick of this [__] I'm sick of the
fascist [__] that women don't have the
[__] right to their bodily autonomy I
tell you what you tell men well we're
gonna [__] force you to get castrated
[__] you don't get to shoot
[__] uh seeds anymore oh God damn
they'd be passing bills and let me tell
you something else Texas Paul if men
could receive abortion Services you
could buy those [__] at a
goddamn gas station on the counter on
the counter you could buy [__]
abortion pills if men could benefit from
them you better believe that [__]
[__] so Rhonda santis and any [__]
Republican anywhere who's writing bills
and restricting access of women's health
care you're on my [__] fighting side
and I'm gonna [__] scream and yell
because I'm an ally for women and their
[__] choices and their health care
and by God if they want to carry a baby
to term and kill themselves and leave
their children families behind fine
whatever your religion says but if you
want to have your choices for your
family between you and your doctor I'm
for that too so get the [__] out of
people's Liberty now right now and this
country should be pissed pissed and not
shut the [__] up about this and this is
the battle that we must wage is the
Battle of women's health care and their
right to it so stay out of it Ron
DeSantis again I'd say I'd be dare
licked my duty if I didn't
mention that and bring that up sorry
about that okay let's uh I know I don't
have a very good transition here
um speaking of I got one yeah I got one
yeah
it doesn't have to be this way that's
right it doesn't have to be this way
vote Democrat are we perfect no are we
way the [__] better than Republicans
hell yes we are hell yes we are well we
work better than Republicans the
Democratic parties anymore because you
can be a [__] Duggar and you can have
16 [__] kids or how many ever kids
you have and you can go to your church
and pray to your [__] Sky Wizard and
I will die for your right to [__] do
it but you will stay the [__] out of my
house
you will stay out of my daughters my
wives my grandchildren's [__]
genitals and mind your [__] business
if you vote Democrat we don't have this
problem anymore
it all goes the [__] away the outrage
machine dies with the Republican [__]
party and we can just worry about Paving
streets building hospitals building
schools
trade jobs
and stop worrying about who's [__]
who
sorry but that's my transition oh that's
good I mean well I I know go ahead I was
just going to say we got I mean if
anyone needs to remember there's a video
from 2015 I think it is and just to give
you an idea of who the Republican party
is and their understanding or rather
lack thereof understanding when it comes
to the female anatomy the guy asked if a
woman
oh God if a woman swallows a camera and
her gynological exam [__] I remember
this where does it go right thinking oh
you just poop it out right it goes to
your stomach
uh
I mean these are these these are the
white fragile men
who are deciding the laws on behalf of
women okay and that was back in 2015
these crazy ideas and misconceptions
about the [__] anatomy of a human go
well past that beyond that before that
and they are still happening to this day
where you have these guys
trying to dictate Women's Health Care
and their rights because they believe
this is how the female body works
you got [__] Ben Shapiro he can't get
his own wife wet so you know what these
[__] could shut the [__] up hey
like George Carl and uh like George
Carlin said have you ever noticed that
that the pro-lifers are who are against
abortion or people you wouldn't want to
[__] in the first place speaking exactly
here's the transition speaking of people
you wouldn't want to [__] in the first
place Donald Trump and Elon Musk are in
a war this morning too Donald Trump is
attacking Elon Musk I I mean this I
think this is stemming from the Twitter
files it face planted
um they thought it was a big win Trump
thought it was a big win taibi thought
it was a big win they went and had
Congressional hearings with the
weaponization committee even though they
were weaponizing the information they
were taking from Twitter the The Limited
information they were taking Twitter to
weaponize it in the weaponization it's
all this crazy [__] but here's the thing
is that Elon Musk ended up thinking
knowing eventually that the Twitter
files was really stupid and it made him
look really bad and I actually think it
put him at legal risk
um that's why he's starting to pull it
and that's why he's backing away from it
um but also Elon Musk is it
he's a Welfare Queen he he lives off the
welfare of our government and US
appropriating funds for him to develop
his
um his companies which is hilarious
Donald I mean I do I I want to point out
the the before we move too far the
funniest part about Elon Musk
complaining about NPR receiving which is
one two percent of their whole their
whole budget right and trying to claim
that oh this is a government this is a
state media company this is they're
government funded
uh like every other Republican and
libertarian and all these [__] cucks
that that want to make these claims it
is them projecting to themselves looking
at themselves in the mirror because Elon
Musk like you pointed out is a welfare
King right he's away he's a [__] he's
a person
[__] yeah not only is he
privilege and the money they received to
start his businesses and invest but also
the money that he gets from the
government alone
to have these businesses
is is hypocritical and hysterical to see
him complain about NPR and complain
about the government and this and that
and that guy's [__] on the other end
being like at least it may have some
more right that is who he is somebody
said welfare horror and I totally agree
with that well here is here's Donald
Trump's attack on Elon Musk this morning
and I don't know if this means that
Donald Trump isn't coming to Twitter
because I really he's officially he
officially came back to Instagram I saw
oh did he so he posted something is that
what you're saying yeah
you'll find it Well um so I I don't know
if he's gonna come back to Twitter or
not I have no idea I figured he would by
the summer at some point especially if
Ron DeSantis got in the race he'd really
have to uh go battle Ron on Twitter
um but here's here's Donald Trump's
statement on fraud social this morning
about Elon Musk he says I don't believe
in on musk voted for Biden not for a
minute okay well all right I don't know
what that means I guess he's saying he
voted for me not not him but okay he
told me that he voted for me oh okay so
he told you personally on the phone okay
so you talk to Elon Musk that seems kind
of funny I don't know just saying it
that Jared Kushner was meeting with you
Elon Musk or was weaning with Elon Musk
and the Saudis who you know Elon Musk is
in the hawk for for Twitter it seems
kind of funny all these things are
connected I don't know maybe I'm just
off my rocker uh he says but who knows
about that and who cares oh who cares Mr
projection I think it's you that cares
that's why you're typing it out on the
old front social but he goes on to say
Elon is just trying to make friends with
the absolutely horrible Biden
administration because of all the
government subsidies that he gets which
Biden isn't actually the one who
determines what subsidies
um Elon Musk gets they're done through
Appropriations through Congress and the
majority of the time the administration
is just the one who has to write the
check that's actually how our government
works I know that no one typically knows
especially Donald Trump who ran the
Bakken executive branch of our
government but you know who's to count
um it's magnomics you know uh Eli let me
get down and all the permits he needs
his space company car company battery
company tunnel company and even Twitter
which is legally controlled by the
illegally controlled by the FBI oh my
God this layers need government help and
subsidies I'm not just yelling out of
nowhere he literally yelled in the
[__] post he said which is illegally
controlled by the FBI need government
help and subsidies that's how he's
anyways how's my phone and I can't get
up he goes on to yell he is just he is
just mending fences quote unquote
mending fences so I I don't know if he's
saying here in Texas Paul I don't know
if Donald Trump's saying that Elon Musk
is trying to get on Biden's good side
and I don't what what what the [__] is
this about I he he's attacking you I
mean I couldn't be happier that well and
they're all in a war with Donald Trump I
couldn't be happier my friend no I'll
tell you what it's the [__] about is
Elon Musk woke up and smelled the
[__] Cesspool of [__] he was sitting
in
Tesla survived because of because of
carbon credits that we [__] made sure
happen not the Republicans Republicans
opposed that [__] the only reason Tesla
survived it's its first few years was
selling carbon credits that's it not
making cars not anything else we kept
that [__] company afloat
every single thing SpaceX every [__]
thing that he has ever succeeded at he
succeeded because we made it happen
and then he turned around bought Twitter
and took a giant [__] [__] on us
because just like Bill [__] Mar he
hangs around with these right wing [__]
the [__] Saudis and Jared Kushner and
all these pieces of [__]
so he's sitting there talking [__] to us
when we're the people that buy his
[__] cars well guess what he woke up
and found out that Twitter's [__]
failing
test was [__] failing the stocks
plummeting you know he woke up and
smelled the [__] he was spreading around
that's what it's all about and [__]
Trump hates it because
you know Trump knows he creates [__]
nothing he has nothing to Elon Musk
other than the drama and the [__] like
that he is nothing and yeah Elon Musk is
finally you remember when we first had
that that argument you asked me he said
who would sip for Elon Musk I said I
would I would a lot of this [__] could
be explained it could have been done
better you know there's factories here
in Texas this that and the other it's
too [__] far gone there's nothing
Elon Musk can do he took his reputation
rip that [__] off threw it on the
[__] ground poured gasoline on it and
lit it on [__] fire I'm couldn't be
happier I couldn't be happier he's such
a dumb [__] I mean there there is there
is not more um of a stupid [__]
in this country than Elon Musk he is the
dumbest son of a [__] I think that that
is alive in this country I really truly
you're from Missouri you're in a
hillbilly boy too you are you may
pretend like you're not but you're from
Missouri you remember you remember
International School like I'm not a
hillbilly what the [__] are you talking
about I'm no Billy through and through
but you remember International Scouts
International Scouts yeah Gabe's pulling
it up he knows where I'm going with this
I think the International Scout so
freaking popular man so hugely popular
Navistar bought International Harvester
and you know the Scout and the pickup
trucks and the travel all went away a
long time ago they're setting the other
well they're coming back baby when when
Elon Musk is trying to sell that [__]
box polished turd as a truck
you have [__] Volkswagen which owns
Navistar is bringing us back the
International Scout
in an eve it's in nothing but EV form
that's it
and then on top of that you've got Elon
Musk [__] torching his own reputation
his own companies everything when all of
this competition is coming down the road
you know since you mentioned
International Scout and the Tesla
non-truck truck thing whatever the [__]
that is whatever the hell that thing is
no one no no pickup owner ever looks at
that and like yeah that's a pickup truck
like we like pickup truck owners don't
even look at El rancheros or El Caminos
and like that's a pic that's not a
pickup truck that's a car with the truck
bed okay that's not a pickup truck all
right like pickup truck owners know what
a [__] pickup is I'm not saying El
rancheras or or El Caminos are bad
they're damn nice guy I love I love a
really [__] nice restored El Camino
because I'm a Chevy guy that's just
where I'd fall but
when you're mentioning um the
International Scout and the non-truck
non-tesla truck it got me thinking like
there is a subculture of people that
that's all like they'll have three
Scouts in their [__] garage one that
they're working on one they restored 20
years ago half ass and one they paid
someone to restore right like it's a
whole community of people just like this
Tesla truck it kind of reminds you of
the the DeLorean right and the story of
the DeLorean because it even kind of
looks like he's like he even tried to
make it look like the DeLorean something
yeah it's definitely like a DeLorean but
they have their own subculture right
like they yeah yeah they got their own
subculture so like literally literally
he's now he's now gonna Battle
subcultures of international Scouts as
if these people are going oh it's this
Scouts and Evie [__] that [__] no
they're gonna go buy those [__]
they're gonna own one and and anyone
whose dad had one or uncle had one or or
man we used to we used to travel around
on the farm is all [__] rusted out
and it was a pile of [__] but man we
drove that all around the farm they're
all gonna go buy one of these even if
they're EVS they don't give a [__]
because it has the name International
Scout and it's part of that subculture
but I I think I think it's laughable
that
um Elon Musk thinks he's
um that he's Steve Jobs and what I mean
by that is Steve Jobs changed the music
industry Steve Jobs changed how you sell
music how you make music how you release
music like he completely changed it he
changed the entire industry and Elon
Musk thought with with his truck he was
gonna change the entire industry and the
entire industry in the entire Market
looked at him and went you're full of
[__] that ain't no truck okay pull that
[__] up man what's that I just I just
sent you a link compare this
to [__] elin's pile of crap
is this the International Scout yeah
yeah the Eevee it's a it's an electric
vehicle 100 through and through electric
100 it goes into it'll be on it'll be
available in 2026.
compare this [__] to the steaming pile
a pile of dog [__] that Elon Musk is
offering people Volkswagen knows how to
design a [__] vehicle well that's
because you're an automobile company
right right that's your truck a long
time that's a bad [__] man it's
a yeah I mean if you look if you look at
what they're now I [__] want you
[__] now I want one of these when is
this when is this coming out 20 20 26.
God damn I was gonna I wanted to go get
uh an F-150 and I'm not a Ford guy but I
wanted to go get the the like 150 yeah
but now I want one of these
[__] I mean you would you would
almost assume
safely assume that a company who
specializes in making trucks
could then say great you know what we
need to do is we need to adapt and we
have our existing infrastructure we just
need to add a technology component and
we need to bring in people who
specialize in that and how do we create
the same good quality product
while also making it EV meanwhile
Elon Musk is like well I have an EV
company
well I'm just gonna make a truck but
also I'm not gonna just like it would be
one thing if it's nice God damn man it
reminds me honestly it reminds me uh
because they're similar in in some of
their designs of the Ford Bronco which
just well well because the international
the the the Scout and the Bronco were
competitive yeah I mean you know you're
either a Bronco fan or you're a scout
fan kind of thing but Bronco they were
but but Ford released the Bronco is is
Ford going to have Broncos EV I know
they got different just released the new
ones I don't know let me see you for
those but if you look at the scout here
um the unique thing about the old Scouts
and the newscasts is out see that front
wheel Hound so far forward
um you know that's a that's a damn good
looking SUV now I like the pickup
um you know because I'm a pickup man I
guess I listened to Joe D yeah so much I
never knew you would the Ford EV is
projected to arrive
around 20 28 2029 and that's that's
going to be in a a Bronco yeah so they
have the new they have the new Bronco
that came into this but it's not TV yet
but it's not Eevee yet right so they br
they brought it back to be like all
right you you guys love the Bronco
there's a whole subculture here people
love it I mean I love the Bronco there's
a guy who has two uh restored Broncos
down the street and I'm almost like ah
man like it's so you know there's that
and there's like a Defender a Defender
it would be also another one that would
be great to have except those things are
[__] guzzlers when it comes to like
Diesel and gas but um
the the the Ford Bronco came back in the
last year year and a half I think it was
and so
there we bringing it back into the
market be like look we have a new
version okay we're not just the old
version that you have to restore we've
got the new version that you can buy off
the lot and then yeah it sounds like in
2028 2029 so you know four or five years
away or what what's the Fox News that
you put in there is there something
that's the no I was just showing the
comparison the oh okay to what the Cyber
truck looks like versus what the uh
International Scout looks like okay well
I'm gonna I wanna keep going here on
this but yeah yeah I'm gonna move on
here because I want to show everyone uh
Grandpa poopy pants is uh this is his
first post on Instagram and he's posted
he's posted two
uh the same type of they're both the nft
speaking of products speaking of new
products coming out what's the nfts oh
my God so you would think you would
think a guy who's running for president
who's desperate to be president so he
can pardon himself from federal crimes
that Jack Smith is going to lay on this
[__] you would think he would be
using any social media platform he can
to like win a race but he's not he's
broke and his main goal is to get money
because he's [__] flat broke so here
is here's his post this is this is his
Instagram account yeah um
this is the first yeah this is mind you
this is the first post that he's made
since 2021 and the last post that he
made in 2021 was about
January 6th now I don't know because you
can see he's got the cufflinks here of
45 because that's a that's a thing with
all these AI developed stolen art things
that he's doing with these things but
he's got the Liberty Bell there which
I'm maybe he's gonna crush it is that
what he is that what he's gonna destroy
it is that what his plan is here I mean
it looks like his plan is to destroy it
maybe but here's the here's the actual
post it says I am pleased oh my God to
inform you due to this great success of
my previously launched digital trading
cards we are doing it again series two
available right now go to link in BIO
like literally
this guy is grifting again with these
nfts series
he must have ran out of money
nah guys well one thing that he does is
just freaking idiotic is he's he loses
money left and right instead of just
cutting [__] off and and taking the L
he dumps when he makes money he dumps it
into his [__] losers
and loses all that money that that's
what he does but you're not gonna
believe
the first round of nfts are selling at
900 bucks a pop right now
I'm not even kidding
who's buying these [__] no but
it is they're three guys three guys that
sell crypto and if nfts went around and
bought them all the [__] up and drove
the price up to twelve hundred dollars
look at these [__] things and now
they're starting to come down and prices
are down to 900 bucks oh my God and then
Here Comes Grandpa poopy pants
he's going to reissue these and he's
going to use those figures that these
dumb asses dumped into they they their
entire [__] fortunes they dumped into
these things because they just knew
during the election that they were going
to sell be able to sell these data and
they will they will your uncle is going
to lose [__] money on these things
he's got he's got one here he's supposed
to look like Elvis was 45. look at him
with a dog he doesn't even like dogs
[__] named Mike dogs he's never
[__] ran a barbecue in his life what
the [__] is this [__] so I sent you a
link for another one uh that is is
incredibly uh I I don't want to stop
this Carousel it's so great I think well
I think my favorite is that is that the
King of Hearts one but yeah that's
Paul's Point like yeah you've got the
people you've got the Maga people who
jump in thinking oh I'm gonna invest in
this car whatever whatever and they're
gonna they're gonna buy high right
they're gonna buy high at the 900 or
whatever it's listed in in the market
right now they're gonna buy that only to
see if [__] drop down and that's what
happened the first time now I haven't
been tracking to see that one back up
but there was a point
there was a point when they originally
launched there was people that were
selling it people bought it and then it
[__] dropped down yeah
I guess it you know people are buying
them
this is real this is let's get this
Trump is going to take those current
trading prices because these [__]
three [__] dumped billions of
dollars into this [__] and he's gonna
take that price that is today and he's
going to sell these for even [__]
more than he sold the first ones I
guarantee you no he can't and he's gonna
pocket he can't sell for more because
you got to remember he's selling it for
99 and there's only gonna be a hundred
that are available
right or I forget how many are total but
the he could only sell these for 99
because it's the whole
9900 800.99 under the amount that is
required to report it and that's the
reason so uh or uh yeah so when you look
at it if you go to the website it says
buy now only 99 and then of course if
you go into the how it works area it's
going to explain to you that you can
only buy let's see how much do they cost
how can I buy on there's a how many in
here here's here's the uh here's the
only 99 right
um so there's oh here we go just like
the last time
oh actually
last time there were 40 oh it's a
[__] oh my God okay so in December he
released 45 000 because of course 45
right but he only said that there were
44 that were available which means that
Trump was selling the Thousand that he
was trying to make money off right the
series 2 version is 47 000 because he's
going for to be number 47 and again
there were only 46 000 available which
means he's only going to have or he's
going to have a thousand that he can
sell on his own and make money so it's
one of those things uh how many can I
purchase if you wanna you can buy up to
47 per purchaser using crypto you can
buy up to a hundred Max per person well
yeah because the more you in crypto
right it's not it's 99 99 I mean 99
times uh 100. look at this he's selling
he's saying you just buy 45 47 cards and
you can have dinner with the pre he's
not the president
he's not he's not the president I just
want to point that out
and folks before Sam bankman freed
collapsed the crypto Market everybody in
the crypto Market was breaking their own
arms patting themselves on the back
about how great crypto was and how
valuable it was and it will always be
valuable and this is the same damn thing
you're buying a digital picture that's
it that's it
buy every single one of them they go
broke because [__] them I don't care and
hey guess what we have our own grift
here on the Tony Michaels podcast I
don't give a [__] I'll say it I'll
promote it [__] em hats you want a real
thing not digital hat it's not a [__]
fake ass hat it's real you buy it you
put it on your look Dex ball got one
he's got the blue one here's the blue
one look how pretty this makes me you
got the blue one look okay look at that
look at that look at that red white blue
right there let's make red it's not
pretty durable again Red Hats wearable
again okay here's what you do it's hat
week here at the Tony Michaels podcast
it's hat week you go to hatchback
where's your [__] hat man I gotta get
I can get it I can get it well he does
have a [__] hand hold on hold on yeah
go ahead and get your [__] take me
down I'll be right back so here's the
thing if you go right now if you go to
hats.thetonymichaels.com that's
hats.thetonymichaels.com or you can just
go to thetonymichaels.com click the [__]
I'm Hance link
here's the promo code listen up folks
here's the promo code hat week 10 that's
hat week the number 10 so hat week one
zero and you get ten percent off your
entire hat purchase I've noticed Texas
Paul what people do is they'll go in and
buy three or four of them they'll buy
three or four hats and um um so you'll
get ten percent off your entire hat
order that's the most important thing so
use the promo code let's break my blue
eyes pop then just make my blue eyes pop
let's see here let's look oh my God look
at that it does
it does let's see Gabe's here oh man
make Red Hats wearable again you're
muted friend does it make my does it
make my red eyes pop yeah it does
you look like a demon so there's there's
the red hat there's the red hat everyone
so if you want to get your own [__]
hat uh it helps the show and we really
appreciate the support and also if you
get your red hat and you want to send a
picture either DM it to me somewhere and
they're on patreon or Twitter or
Instagram if you want it to be public
just post it tag me and I'll I'll see if
I can get it um on my timeline somewhere
so just just go to
hats.thetonymichaels.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com click the hat store
link and you'll go to the hat store and
you'll be able to get 10 off if you use
the promo code this week hat week 10 hat
week one zero so get 10 off your hat
order thank you for joining us Texas
fall as always it's great to have you on
Tuesday everybody the link for Texas
Paul is down below his website go to
realtexaspaul.com that's
realtexaspaul.com follow him everywhere
join him on Sundays for his YouTube show
so follow his YouTube channel speaking
of YouTube go ahead and subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast right now you're
not going to want to miss a single show
we are every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific as long as Twitter's still alive
follow us over there at Tony Michaels
pod download every single episode
of the Tony Michaels podcast on Apple's
Spotify Google it's free to download
over there the other thing is freeze to
follow us on Facebook if you still have
a Facebook account go to the Tony
Michaels and also I want to tell you if
you have an Amazon Prime account you can
actually give us some of Amazon's money
for free it doesn't cost you a thing
here's what happens if you got an Amazon
Prime account go link it to your Twitch
account or open a Twitch account and
Link the two you get one free
subscription on Twitch with your Amazon
Prime account and you have to re-renew
it every month but you give us that one
free subscription we get a couple bucks
each month but it all adds up and you're
the best audience in the world we love
having you here the chat family the [__]
them family is the most fantastic family
on the internet and we have some of the
best mods to give the mods some love in
the chat it's been a great show I love
dunking on DeSantis almost the entire
time and I love the idea of Ron you know
what I love a cage match Donald Trump
Rhonda Santos and Elon Musk I um I think
I think we should put a little bit they
bring it back are they bringing back
Celebrity Death Match I think so that's
what we should do have a cage match
between those three that's what we
should do hey you're gonna do you're
gonna do a show on Little Jimmy Jordan
and Alvin Bragg that would be a great
cage match because right now yeah Alvin
Bragg is just kicking those yeah
yeah but it's almost like he's got he's
got Bob wire bat Bragg does and he's
gonna beat that ever loving [__] out of
Jim Jordan's obstruction that's the
truth that's the truth and that's you
come here every day for the truth
because this microphone kills fascism
same time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[__] [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal-born headass Beacon